uh if you see a great deal and it's a
cis white guy
i'm not saying like a greek kid from
brooklyn or something
would would you consider in the next
couple of years
uh syndicating an a non-underestimated
founder if it was like a great deal and
you just thought
this or are you going to stick to the
mission and just say that's it we're
just understand it's not even a mission
man
like you understand you understand
okay let me see if i can do a quick
analogy go
if you were just the if you were just
you just had the best deal flow of your
life
when it came to um uh any anybody in
silicon valley because we'll take it
back there we'll do two things two birds
one stone sure
anybody in silicon valley that was in
five mile radius of you
you just had everybody picked up the
phone and called you which probably
happens anyway
you just had that and then i said to you
and this is going to be count the people
are going to be confused by my this
analogy but and then i said to you
there there is uh just to you know i'm
gonna do it opposite
let's say you were only you were just
only only only doing
cloud cloud deals right you're doing
cloud deals all day
and someone said man i got this great
real estate over here yeah
yeah great real estate you don't
understand this real estate is going to
three x in a year yeah
this is a 10x in two years you
you might you know throw a little pebble
at it you might say i'll see what
happens but you're not gonna put
everything into that
right you're gonna you're gonna become
you're gonna dominate in cloud
right i don't i don't i get requests
from white men to invest there's a
couple of times in the last 12 months
where i've asked a couple of white men
can i put in 5 000 or 10 000 personally
and i do that because it
it it absolutely that money is in a
certain account
that any money i make i invest in other
people so i
i say that but i've invested in 130 plus
companies
i've looked at 6 000 that were by under
represented underestimated founders
i've been asked every day of my life
almost to invest
everywhere else and i have the
discipline to say no
i am so bullish on us i couldn't i
couldn't be more
well i always tell people if you have an
advantage to like you have to press the
advantage you have
and so for you to close a deal with an
underrepresented founder would take you
half as long as anybody else
right they want you on the cap table
right yeah
and that's people don't understand how
different that is
um from buying public equities anybody
can buy a share on netflix but imagine
if
you know the ceo of netflix was like
well who are you and why do you want to
buy shares of my company
and can i get some references right
that's
the world we live in which is you know
your reputation matters in getting you
on that captain
yeah because i'm sure when you were when
you were stu like
hit had those couple of hits at first
yeah i'm sure
you had a lot of uh distraction where
people were like why don't you put your
money in this
oh god i get it and they were trying to
guess your bank account and they were
just why don't you put your money in
this
movies i'm i'm here yeah like i'm
here i'm here so i'm here i
if if a company that um asked me to
you know i got the deal flow and it was
by a white man and and
he did really well i would just be like
great you know you got a coupon code for
it like i'd love to check it out you
know you and your yacht and on your
billions
i'm happy for you that's not the game
i'm in
i don't want to win that game